[Music]
happy Friday welcome back to certified
country I am selfish lazy and today in
the studio we have cam joining me
promised I didn't know he was your man
there was a response to the song Jolene
Naomi about the catalyst I have friends
whose parents have gone through
infidelity who their marriages have gone
through infidelity and I wanted to as a
songwriter create a world where they
would get the apology and the healing
they did not get in real life what do
you do when you're put in that hard
situation do you resort to slut-shaming
do you get competitive and adversarial
or do you step up and you have integrity
and you tell the truth you know when you
try and do the right thing by each other
and it's it's a very I feel like it's a
very good kind of woman bonding moment -
is this a good representation of what we
can expect on the full Lang ya dream of
having a hit like burning house when you
have such an outlier kind of song like
that I'd have that work in a really like
organic genuine way it doesn't make me
feel like oh I better stay in the rules
and the lane and the whatever mainstream
it's like no I can just do me and I just
dug super deep with the songwriting
[Music]
I feel like this is definitely my best
set of songs to date I want to talk a
little bit about how Diane you know the
timing of this song it's a really
interesting time for women right now
yeah what you posted about Harvey
Weinstein I thought was really really
good yeah you said well watching Harvey
Weinstein's legacy implode and fall from
the heavens in a burning mass of flames
not subtle at all
I've spoken with women who had similar
experiences across all kinds of
industries including country music and
you you know went on and on here I
appreciate that you reference that it's
not isolated to one industry though
right it's it's across the board
first off I'm really heartbroken but so
happy for the healing that's happening
on so many people that feel they can
finally speak up because that is such an
important step and even though that
doesn't mean they're gonna be safe it
doesn't mean those women are still gonna
keep their jobs
it doesn't mean that people are actually
gonna believe them even though it's a
really hard road ahead like it makes me
really happy that everyone's on the
journey together I use the word feminist
for me that is not being angry that's
not anything except saying I just want
to empower women to feel like equals and
I want to inspire men to treat us like
equals and I think naturally that comes
but there's something along the way that
gets a little twisted I still get people
that comment you know I don't I don't
need feminism that didn't do anything
for me I'm my own individual and I think
understanding like the history of where
we've come from and not getting ahead of
ourselves because you yes there are a
lot of things that we haven't in
privileges that we're enjoying right now
especially white women and it's easy to
think everything's fine and for a lot of
women that's not the case and also if
you forget where you came from it's a
really slippery slope to have it move
backwards so I think everyone's trying
hard in it underneath
everybody wants what's best for
everybody I really do believe that
whether you agree with me or whether you
don't
I think the most important thing is to
just don't let the anger
you'd be from talking about it with
people that have different views cuz
that's what's gonna get everybody to the
right spot it's no secret that it's been
an issue in radio yang country radio
yeah yeah it's a major issue that's uh
something that I specifically
experienced when people come to me and
they go oh aren't you so happy about the
Renaissance that's happening of women
there's so many women artists when you
have one female artist in the top 50 on
a chart mm-hmm that is not a Renaissance
when you have like such a small number
of program directors working in radio
that are women like that tiny number
that's not a renaissance when you have
the heads of labels not being women
that's not a Renaissance like we still
have a lot of work to do yeah it's just
it's it's frustrating there's like a
weird myth that women don't listen
that's one of the excuses because women
don't like listening to women like
that's a thing that they say there's a
lot of myths that people have been fed
like program directors they were told
don't play to women next to each other
in the playlist and some of them don't
play to in an hour is crazy isn't that
weird
what's funny is that country music is
traditionally like we have powerhouse
female vocals
[Music]
we have super strong female writers we
have I mean the 90s and the 2000s I had
all these incredible female artists
there's some weird turn of events that
has happened with where radio is at
right now and whoever the scientist is
that can look into that
zoom in and we got to talk about the Sam
Smith song so Tyler my musical brother
was working with Sam on his album and he
had shown Sam one of the songs from my
album they up coming out and he said we
should write with her I'd love to do
that so I come in and like I don't play
guitar all that often and Tyler goes
okay you're playing the guitar today and
I was like no I don't think about that
and Sam goes I think he'd be so noisy I
was like yes whatever you need that
sounds great
so I played guitar and he had this idea
for like the ghost of you like you're
kind of revisiting this person that you
used to be in love with and we built
this beautiful song that's about
visiting the plate the physical spots in
your mind that you had relationship you
built this palace but it's the one that
didn't work out you're visiting the
ruins of this palace he built with this
X and it's just so poetic and beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to have Sam Smith sing to me and say
real love is never a waste of time like
yes that is so good just stop you crying
it's a sign of the times no big deal
that you just opened for Harry Styles at
the Ryman
[Music]
Harry does such a good job with his fans
they all trust him because he like give
so much love and like really takes care
of them and they take care of each other
so playing that night I was so happy to
be in a room full of like all these
women and it was in the mother church
and the Ryman I just was like you know
having a great time talking them between
songs and then they'd be silent
listening to all the words and then at
the end they you know I've obviously
sang along to burning house and then
standing ovations I was I could like cry
thinking about it and then he comes out
and it is pandemonium like full-blown
screaming you need earplugs it's like be
in there they love him I mean everybody
loves him but just like it is it's a
really special bond that they all have
and it's it was a cool thing to witness
and he talks about getting together in
the studio collaborator whoo Wow no but
that'd be fire yeah we're talking about
an ex thank you so much for joining yeah
talk to you wait to hear the new album
thank you guys so much for watching be
sure to come back and see us again next
Friday we'll be right here on YouTube
[Music]